قبل حدوث تدخلات عسكرية خطيرة، كان ينبغي على
أعضاء البرلمان الذين
تم انتخابهم بالطبع لتمثيل
الشعب أن يقولوا كلمتهم.
لنكن صادقين، المملكة المتحدة ليس
لديها سجل جيد عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالتدخل العسكري خاصة في الشرق
الأوسط اليوم  نكرر هذا النداء
ونطالب جميع الأطراف في هذا
الصراع بالموافقة على وقف فوري لإطلاق النار. لقد
قُتل الكثير من الأطفال الأبرياء
بالفعل، وقد حان الوقت
لإنهاء هذه الانتخابات غير الإنسانية، وهو ما
يمثل فرصة كبيرة
لاسكتلندا، واليوم أريد أن أخبركم
كيف  أعتقد أنه يمكننا معًا ضمان
أفضل النتائج لبلدنا، لذا دعونا نكون
واضحين تمامًا في البداية، لقد
انتهى سوناك، لقد انتهى من رئيس الوزراء، لقد
انتهى المحافظون والحمد
لله.